878 in this year in midwinter after
Twelfth Night the enemy army came
stealthily to Chippenham and occupied
the land of the West Saxons and settled
there and drove a great part of the
people across the sea and conquered most
of the others and the people submitted
to them except King Alfred he journeyed
a difficulties through the woods and fen
fastnesses with a small force and the
same winter the brother of Ivor and half
dana was in the kingdom of the West
Saxons in Devon with 23 ships and he was
killed there and eight hundred and forty
men of his army with him and there was
captured the banner which they called
Raven and afterwards at Easter King
Alfred with a small force made a
stronghold at Ethel knee and he and the
section of the people of Somerset which
was nearest to it proceeded to fight
from that stronghold against the enemy
then in the seventh week after Easter he
rode to Egberts stone east of Sellwood
and there came to meet him all the
people of Somerset and of Wiltshire and
of that part of Hampshire which was on
this side of the sea and they rejoiced
to see him and then after one night he
went from that encampment to illy and
after another night to Edington and
there fought against the whole army and
put it to flight and pursued it as far
as the fortress and stayed there a full
heart
and then the enemy gave him preliminary
hostages and great oaths that they would
leave his kingdom and promised also that
their King should receive baptism and
they kept their promise
three weeks later King Guthrum with
thirty of the men who were most
important in the army came to him
two ala which is near athelney and the
king stood sponsor to him at his baptism
there and the unbinding of the christen
took place at Wedmore and he was twelve
days with the king and he honored him
and his companions greatly with gifts
[Music]
you